Welcome back everyone it's charlie hbo just
announced house of the dragon season 2 as we
all probably expected so i'll do my early top
10 predictions and explain what's going on with
season two just in general because there have
been a lot of questions about how they're gonna
plot out the show like how many seasons is it
gonna last george r martin and the showrunners
have talked about that like how many seasons they
have planned and what their plan is for after the
events of this series i'm in the middle of doing
episode videos for house of the dragon and yes
of course i will do episode videos for however
many other spin-offs and prequel shows they do
like i'll be 90 years old someday doing videos
for like the 20th game of thrones prequel series
but careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far so starting with
number 10 house of the dragons season 2 will
begin probably with the assault of harrenhal
what they might wind up doing is ending season
one with like the black council because we see
a version of that in the trailer that actually
could be from one like the last episodes is sort
of like the tipping point when the actual fighting
starts to begin in the dance of the dragon civil
war like when the actual battles really do begin
the cool thing about the assault on heron hall
and a lot of the other battles like pretty much
all the major engagements during the actual dance
of the dragons become really dark parallels for
big fights that happened during aegon's conquest
and there were a lot of easter eggs for game of
thrones during episode 1 the same thing continues
throughout the rest of the series and all the
different events so like they'll be easter eggs
for stuff that happens way later in the timeline
as well speaking of which number nine more of the
characters will probably find out about aegon's
prophecy of a song of ice and fire there's already
been a lot of people wondering if there's going
to eventually be more of a direct connection with
what's happening at the wall in the events of the
dance of the dragons but that remains to be seen
because during this part of the timeline the white
walkers just were not very active the way that
george r martin explains it though is that like
each new targaryen king that would come along
would be told the secret of a song of ice and fire
aegon's prophecy but each brand new king believed
that it was right around the corner so for example
viserys has been king for about nine ten years
when the show picks up in present day for that
entire time he's been completely preoccupied kind
of paranoid that white walkers could potentially
attack at any moment so think of all the crazy
stuff that happens to him just during episode
one on top of all that he's been kind of paranoid
about white walkers this whole time too and now
rhaenyra kind of seems like she's gonna be that
way too like i know becoming queen ruling over a
kingdom is a really big job everyone's gonna try
and kill you but also on the side there's gonna
be this world-ending threat that you have to deal
with potentially at any moment it could come at
any moment because all the characters during this
period didn't know that it wasn't going to happen
for like another 200 plus years they thought that
it was gonna happen right around the corner number
eight talk about more game of thrones easter eggs
viserys will probably die before the end of the
season every season on game of thrones there was
always some huge wtf episode right before the
end of the season where either someone major or
many major people died at the same time or there
was some epic battle sometimes multiple battles
house of the dragon is no different in viserys
in the story just like in the grand scheme of
things during the dance of the dragons is kind of
like your sean being ned stark type of character
destined to die because the actual dance is
the battle over the succession and you can't
have an actual battle for the succession until
there is nobody sitting on the iron throne so
metaphorically he has to get off the iron throne
by dying if you look at him in all the trailers
for future episodes he doesn't look so hot and
not a whole bunch of time goes by like there is
a bit of a time jump but not that much time number
seven currently the showrunners miguel sapochnick
ryan condell and george r martin say that they
have about four seasons planned they might make
it five seasons because fives just sounds like
a rounder number and so much crazy stuff happens
battles had ended didn't mean the actual war was
over there was still a lot of stuff that happened
after that number six in the trailer you see a
group of young children later in the timeline
two of them with white hair those are twin girls
they're daemon's twin daughters baela and rhaena
with an older version of laena targaryen and the
two brunettes are rhaenyra's children with laner
valerian jacaerys and lucerys and that's during
season one we're talking about and because of
the time jumps during season two we'll probably
see the older versions of the characters and
their dragons because all of them all four of them
here become dragon riders number five speaking of
dragons there are 17 total that they said they'd
feature during the entire series we'll probably
see most of the rest of them by the end of season
two maybe not like every single one but most of
the rest of them later on in the timeline some
of them are like brand new hatchlings during the
dance of the dragons so they're super tiny in hand
in hand with at number four we'll also meet most
if not all the dragon seeds in season two that
were part of the dance of the dragons dragon seeds
are people who are dragon riders and have dragons
like there are a lot of people who are eventually
born in the targaryen family who have the gene for
dragon riding but don't bond with dragons because
these are the powers that be won't let you have a
dragon because of something you've done or there's
just not enough living dragons to go around so
there aren't like infinite dragons for every
single person who is capable of riding a dragon
and remember this is meant to be a targaryen
civil war with dragons fighting dragons in the
air so not all the dragons are going to survive
so eventually the available pool of dragons
to potentially bond with just gets smaller and
smaller number three we'll probably see an older
version of vernier be married to daemon targaryen
like when they meet in episode one daemon is about
12 years older than her and she's very young so
like they're not together together he just really
cares about her but they try to let you know that
there's just like this weird thing that the two
of them have between them like you're just kind
of waiting for them to actually get together at
some point but currently when the show begins
he is married to rhea royce and his brother the
king is very much alive brener's father and he
absolutely hates the idea hates the idea of daemon
ever being with his daughter so there's a lot of
roadblocks that have to get out of the way before
the two of them actually get together for real a
lot of you've also asked like why doesn't younger
rhaenyra here just get married to daemon if they
do a lot of sister wiving in their family like
if it's a normal thing why don't they just get
married right now remember first daemon is already
married but also daemon's brother her father hates
the idea but i think later in the trailer where
you see him attack daemon with the valyrian dagger
the cat's paws dagger i think he's learned that
daemon has secretly married to her but that's like
way later in the timeline but like during other
scenes where you see them bond their blood here
that is ranira and daemon getting married like
we saw that in the very first teaser so you know
eventually they will get married but it doesn't
happen until way way later so if we saw it in the
first teaser for season one that means it's gonna
happen during season one they'll enter season two
probably having been married for a good long while
and they'll probably have at least two of their
children number two just talking about the actual
premiere because they're not gonna start filming
either be the civil war in the riverlands like
there are a couple really big battles and they
also have the deaths of a couple really important
people and some really epic backstabbing that goes
on like shocking red wedding level backstabbing
or they could do that as like a season two episode
eight or episode nine and then the finale would
be like the aftermath of that they've done that in
previous game of thrones seasons before where like
your craziest events happen just a couple episodes
before the finale and what they said that they're
going to do because they only have like four or
five seasons planned they have their ending in
sight already they know exactly how they're gonna
end the show whatever the final season winds up
being the show will continue after that but what
they'll do is like the next season will treat like
an anthology show and they'll cover a different
time period so like if they go to five seasons
season six would be like aegon's conquest with
a completely different cast during a different
part of the timeline and they do that for like
four or five seasons and then after that jump to
another part of the timeline and what their plan
is is instead of creating like a whole different
show they'll just call it house of the dragon for
like they could go as long as they want just
jumping around in the timeline doing an anthology
style there at least like seven other spin-offs
and prequels that they have in the works right now
so not all of them will be house the dragon shows
it is always possible that they have a second show
running at the same time that house of the dragon
is running in future seasons but i think for right
now they just have plans to do one show at a time
what'll happen because we're pretty early in the